leading anti-racism scholar that's ibram
x kendi is calling for justice after a
grand jury cleared police officers
of any charges for the killing of briana
taylor former detective brett hankinson
was indicted on three counts of
wanton endangerment for shooting into an
occupied home next door
taylor an emergency medical worker was
shot and killed by police as you know
during a botched drug raid in march
after her boyfriend shot at them
thinking it was a robbery
kendy tweeted in part yesterday that to
be black in america is to walk in the
valley of the shadow of pain and death
and right now our lover brianna taylor
is filling us with
rage kendy is a cbs news contributor and
professor at boston university
and the author of new york times
bestseller how to be an anti-racist and
he joins us this morning
i'm so glad you're here this morning
because i got to tell you this is
extremely hard to process
you know number one to hear that there
were charges all right but it was
because of shots fired into the
apartment next door where no one was
killed
brianna taylor in her own home unarmed
was shot six
times and no one is going to be held
accountable
how are we to process this
i think many people particularly many
black people
are processing and black women in
particular black women in particular it
just seems like a
yet another slap but go ahead
no it does and and it seems as if
black women it seems as if if black
people
are simply not being protected and
defended
in the court of law particularly as it
relates to
police officers it does not seem it is
blatantly apparent to people that when
it comes to
an unarmed black woman and white cops
that they are not essentially equal in
the face of the law and that's a problem
there is not equal justice
you know why did those officers have to
shoot 32 times
you know in that apartment when someone
clearly was
thinking that they were being robbed i i
mean it's just unfathomable to people
and it's
and it's enraging to many of us and yet
it keeps happening but some will say
listen the court system has spoken there
was an
investigation and maybe it's time just
to affect to accept the facts of the
investigation
i mean even the attorney general
yesterday said sometimes
you know the the law doesn't always go
along with what has happened that he
followed the case law
as it is written
well then the case law needs to be
re-read because you know
as as mark the king said there are laws
that are just
and there are laws that are unjust and
so if the argument is that this is the
case law then clearly
brianna taylor did not cause her own
death
the people who killed her should be held
to account
for her not still being with us right
now for her not being one of those
people
right now on the front lines fighting
coronavirus
yeah i hate that it's become a black
white issue because it is a black woman
but
should should white people be concerned
about this as well
i think it's it's white people can can
certainly look at
the fact that black people are
disproportionately being killed
by police but they could also see that
white people are being killed at higher
levels in the united states
by the police than than people in other
countries and even for white people
it's very difficult to charge let alone
convict
an officer who who ended up killing an
american citizen and and so to me this
is a part of a larger problem that i
think all americans should recognize
yeah i can't help but think what the
outcome would be if it had been three
white officers i mean three black
officers
who had shot a 26 year old white emt who
was serving on the front lines i can't
help but think
how different maybe this case would have
been yeah his life was on the cusp of
changing
ibrahim it's tiny to colpol uh thank you
for joining us this morning
i want i want to ask you to address
directly an
entrenched idea out there particularly
in white america something i hear from
viewers in fact
just this morning i heard from viewers
you mentioned uh black people
disproportionately likely to be killed
by police
it is pointed out to me often that oh
well that must be because they are
disproportionately likely to be involved
in violent crime so i was just sent
today
the fbi data on on arrest and there are
more black arrests around violent crimes
when i get that response from viewers
when you hear that
point of view that idea what's your
reaction to it
i i just don't see the relationship
again especially they're saying
because black people according to the
fbi data are involved in more violent
crime
it then follows that they would be in
more violent altercations with police so
like with like
and therefore this is just what what's
to be expected
well i i think we we need to first and
foremost
reimagine what the cause is so again
it's either because black people are so
violent and they're so reckless with the
police
and that's why they're being
disproportionately killed in other words
there's something wrong with black
people or there's something wrong with
our criminal justice system
and and i i've been arguing for months
that to say there's something wrong with
any group of people any racial group of
people
is to express a racist idea and
to me there are people who are white
who who engage in violent altercations
with police
and those police officers use restraint
they de-escalate the situation
and which is precisely what they should
be doing with that white person
just as they should be doing with with
black people but they're not
doing it with black people because of
this idea that black people are
dangerous violent animals that need
to to which they need to use lethal
force because they fear for their lives
it's a symptom of a deeper issue
it is and and that's why for me we can
be critical of
police officers rightfully so but let's
not forget that americans commonly
believe that black people in black
neighborhoods are more dangerous
that that americans commonly connect
blackness with criminality and danger
and so this is this is a large-scale
sort of problem just as
you know police officers don't write
laws and
and certainly you know attorney
general's you know
and so we need really a change of even
in our case law and we certainly should
not be protecting
anyone who is killing another american
yes exactly
including people taking shots at police
officers i also think that is just as
egregious
on the flip side uh thank you very much
ibram x candy may we just say
congratulations on your time 100
honor you are on the time 100 most
influential people list
it just goes to show your work is more
needed now than ever before
congratulations to you
can't wait to get my copy thank you
you're welcome sir